roll the ice-cream scene do you think
that will make ice cream sales go
through the roof when people see this
will be on Valentine's Day for the ice
cream companies I hope so
and which flavour was it in that scene
that you guys were doing that was a
dairy-free low sugar coconut ice cream
because I can't have dairy I'm sexy what
was it like sort of taking the
motherhood role in this in this film you
know putting on the baby bump that's
sort of like you know doing that it's
always really funny to do that it's
really fun especially when you when you
like have a baby bump and then pretend
to smoke a cigarette or like a drink a
beer or something you know but it's
funny that's the best part about making
movies is to do funny things like that
true any sort of selfies to the parents
like whoops I'm surprised yeah yeah
precisely Jamie do you think his what is
his suit - shirtless ratio in this movie
would you say oh I get I feel like if
he's not in a suit he's naked
right so probably like 5050 no I don't
know yeah it did you like take anything
from the set to keep from the red-room
or any sort of memento to remember this
trilogy no I didn't after the first film
Jamie gave me something something from
the Red Room that I have he framed it I
don't need anything else
what is it I can't tell you
um this soundtrack is awesome too like
there's so much good stuff with Rita or
of course being in the movie is there
any song or something that you would
have loved to have had on the soundtrack
like is there something that you're
playing right now that you think oh man
that would've been great to film that
scene with that song no my my taste in
music is a bit different than than the
soundtrack of the although I do learn a
lot about like top 40 hits from these
movies okay cool so when you're when
you're in the scenes when you're you
know doing the sex scenes is it is it
get easier at the end of this journey
like a now is it sort of like yeah no I
wish but no it in a way got even more
difficult because there's so many of
them and it's um becomes a real it takes
a lot of physical and mental preparation
to do those kinds of things and it's the
amount of anxiety surrounding it is very
taxing so it just at a certain point Oh
doing it over and over again is is a bit
it's difficult but we did it got through
it yeah
are you happy with how this what we
turned out like are you proud I'm so
proud I'm so proud I'm so happy and I'm
I I hope the fans are happy I hope they
feel proud we've really made the third
one especially for the fans and and I
think that yeah I'm grateful and I'm and
I'm happy one last thing yes because
it's Valentine's Day and the last time
we met we did IKEA furniture we you you
did the sexy Fifty Shades voice do you
think you could do a sexy reading of
these two uh Valentine's Day try I'm so
jet-lagged that I'm not I'm not like
particularly flirty I had Justin on
another planet do um I read both of them
yeah please okay
a Valentine for my wife you know I've
always loved that thing you do that one
special skill only you seem to have I
call it the ability to put up with me
happy Valentine's Day nailed it
you make my eyes happy you make my lips
happy you make my heart happy I could
keep heading south but I think you get
the idea
happy Valentine's Day hello that wasn't
pervy dang I mean that was in a grocery
store yeah what yeah what grocery store
in Canada was Loblaws not about a
hustler grocery store thank you very
much yeah she ate it